a new Pew Research study says that a
record number of young people now doubt
the very existence of God there it is
it's incredible
well obviously the person most upset by
the news
is God in response God has reinvented
himself to appeal more to young people
that's the premise he's here with us
tonight
please welcome God 2.0 wow that's uh
that's some costume you got there God oh
yeah well my name is like God anymore at
the rothko okay all right so I
understand you're trying to appeal to
young people is that the bit here oh
yeah it's great instead of sending
people to hell I just defriend them on
Facebook
I'm also appearing in a lot of medical
marijuana clinics legalize it that's
that's cool I suppose well check out my
new ink oh is that a dragon you bet it
is
you bet your ass Kat Von D druid gonna
get the whole sleeve done eventually are
you gonna pray to someone with a dragon
tattoo on their arm yeah those people
are called narcs that reminds me
someone has a really lame prayer I'll
retweet it for a laugh like last week
when you prayed for a spa day with the
boy band One Direction I got a lot of
retweets okay no one needs to know about
my personal prayers you hipster got
nothing I don't think we're gonna like
this new you I tell ya well they can
suck it you've seen my ratings it's all
about the young sinners okay I have a
young audience anything you want to say
to them on the eighth day I said I'll
kick anyone's ass in halo three talking
to use which came from sorry I'm talking
to you skater thug 91 Roscoe's coming
for you with the plasma cannon outta
here so you can kill people with
tsunamis you ask well they gotta come in
kids get cancer don't think you're funny
huh you're around kids are dying just my
way of thinning the herd
I'm really mad at you what you killed my
grandmother yeah well she oh boy she's
in Hell now
she missed math once you're an awful guy
yeah I'm pretty bad yeah
what are you texting now I'm trying to
talk to you I'm just tweeting a picture
of my but I just said it here
[Music]